yesterday a really big deal was made
about a quote major Donald Trump
economic policy speech now I was shocked
because basically every Trump speeches
him reading polling numbers insulting
people and using words like tremendous
and terrific over and over again but no
this was billed as a major economic
policy speech sadly it was just a
disjointed combination of myths lies and
bogus ideas let's go through a few of
them and I'll put a list up for those of
you that are watching along with me to
begin with Trump started with the the
normal labor force participation
conspiracy suggesting that the
unemployment rate is actually somewhere
between 21 and forty-two percent we've
debunked this many many times he's
including retired people in there he's
including junior and senior high school
students who are not working he's
including parents who are choosing to
stay at home he's including people who
opted to work part-time that's a totally
debunked conspiracy theory Trump also
claimed that former Secretary of State
Hillary Clinton has proposed quote one
of the biggest ever tax increases which
he said would target middle-class
Americans actually Hillary Clinton
hasn't proposed that but there's I wish
I had more to debunk that but she just
hasn't proposed that Trump also promised
that he would repeal quote disastrous
Obamacare saving another two million
American jobs well that's a common
Obamacare myth uh-oh bhama care is not
going to be repealed Obamacare has not
killed jobs we're in the middle of one
of the biggest private sector job growth
periods on record for decades uh so that
is absolutely bogus Donald Trump also
claimed that the US has the highest
business tax rate among the major
industrialized nations of the world at
thirty five percent which he would slash
to no more than fifteen percent will
turns out that the effective tax rate is
already 12 point six percent it is true
that on paper the top marginal corporate
tax rate for the biggest businesses is
thirty-five percent but you know and I
know and Louis knows and most of the
people listening know
very few businesses actually pay that
you consider tax credits other
mechanisms offshoring etcetera etcetera
12.6 % is actually the effective tax
rate paid that's not high at all Trump
also saying Hillary would tax on small
businesses by as much as nearly fifty
percent but nothing in her plan says
that she would do that Trump also saying
he would eliminate the death tax aka the
estate tax you might not know this louis
but the estate tax already exempt its
estates up to five million dollars there
are fewer than one in five hundred
americans who even are subject to that
tax because 499 out of 500 Americans
don't have a states that are five
million dollars Trump would increase
that exemption to 10.9 million dollars
real fighter for the middle class huh
and lastly he would put a moratorium on
all new government regulations I mean
that's just ridiculous Louis if there
are regulations that are needed
regulations are needed saying you're
just going to not do any regulation is
bogus absolutely nothing here coherent
or based in fact the funniest one is is
moratorium on government regulations how
does that mean yeah i mean what all of a
sudden uh when drones are flying through
the air we're okay no no regulations
even though we have this new thing
happening uh we'll just let the the
chaos ensue yeah absolutely no changes
at all the government will not get
involved in anything period now if you
knew about Trump's so-called economic
team you probably wouldn't be surprised
that it's essentially gibberish that
came out of this quote major economic
speech Trump's so-called economic
advisors are basically a microcosm of
his campaign his 13-person economic
advisory team is all male and has very
few economist so as usual it's yet
another boys club with no experts on the
subject matter representative of the
broader problems in Trump's campaign and
chances are they they are incompetent
because that also seems to be a theme
throughout his uh with his campaign
staff everything is opposite with Donald
Trump one of his big sales pitches about
himself is I'm gonna put the best people
around me when I don't know i will put
the best people around me
uh and then he comes up with
spokespeople Keely Baumgardner and
Katrina Pearson who say they don't
actually speak on behalf of Donald Trump
well you've been hired as a spokesperson
so I thought you did and can't put
together a coherent argument on any
national news outlets oh yeah the entire
I'll put the best people around me thing
not really making sense I've talked
about how people of all ages but
particularly Millennials are owning cars
less and participating more in the
sharing economy and one of the more
popular options is zip car which gets
you a car when you want it when you need
it they offer all sorts of cars SUVs
hybrids whatever you need it includes
insurance and it includes gas you just
pay for the time that you actually use
the car and you can reserve the car
online from your smartphone over the
phone then you unlock it with your
zipcard each car share member reduces
their personal co2 emissions by between
1100 and 1,600 pounds per year for our
audience zipcar is offering $25 a free
driving credit if you sign up at joined
zipcar dot-com / David support our show
reduce your carbon emissions and you're
spending on cars sign up at join zipcar
dot-com slash david